a
[Musik]
die soldatinnen und soldaten es ist
wieder mal soweit angenommen in der
ultras kaserne ist darf sie recht
herzlich begrüßen eben zu dieser
angelobung des entwicklungs terminus
märz 2021 105 grunde dienstleistende
rekruten sind angetreten und werden dann
als jährlicher höhepunkt das
treuegelöbnis sprechen
flankiert wird ist dieser festakt
einerseits von ihren zug unter dem
kommandanten stabs wachtmeister markus
horsch wir haben keine kosten und mühen
gescheut und einen erfahrenen und das
ist hier der gerade bei uns wird diese
tätigkeiten wahrnehmen
des weiteren in gewohnter art und weise
als bekannt und beliebt die militärmusik
niederösterreich unter dem kommando von
oberstleutnant
adolf obendrauf und last but not least
die ist das des heutigen nachmittags
unter anführungszeichen
wie schon erwähnt 105 rekruten des
enricos termines märz 2021 ein korrektiv
bei uns in der ersten bands auch hits
party angetreten hier unter dem kommando
von hauptmann mario völkel die
eingetretene gruppe wurde formiert vom
kommandanten der selbigen
dies ist heute der stellvertretende
bataillonskommandeur oberstleutnant eric
graf das feldzeichen voltaire und
eingängiger militärmusik übernommen
lassen sie mich bitte kurz ein paar
worte zum feldzeichen verlieren
das feldzeichen gilt als symbol für den
kommandanten rausgewählt wurde in
früheren zeiten weiß so konnte das
kennzeichen des gegners die besitz
genommen werden
die schlacht für diese
es ist die sollten dann konnten die
tiger brigade sprecher christian arbeit
das wetter programmpunkt nach der
meldung an bord das ist die bundesliga
das abschreiten der front unter den
klängen des präsentiermarsch und last
but not least die große fragen beraten
zu den dingen des kanals machen
[Musik]
es folgen grußworte des aus hirn
kommandant des ausbildungs und
schutzbataillons nummer drei oberst hans
peter uhl im anschluss finden
[Musik]
wenn rekruten sind am ersten märz zum
bundesheer in die wohl stars kaserne
nach mistelbach eingelebt und haben
jetzt bereits ihre ausbildung
erfolgreich abgeschlossen
das freut mich als materials kommandant
und das finde ich auch dass sie in kürze
das neue erlebnis auf die österreich
sprechen werden
in diesen großen moment habe ich noch
ihre angehörigen rannte bekannte eine
würdest du ihn übers internet recht
herzlich begrüßen müssen
es wäre mir lieber gewesen gegen sie
werden jetzt hier mit ihrer angst hätten
sie auch zu schätzen unseren recht
gegeben die sich auch verdient haben
es macht uns aber unsere guten die
ehrenformation die schienen zu gehen
es ist ist die panzerhaubitze batterie
zu der sie direkt in essen vertreten sie
es einrichten
mit stolz öffentliche tragen und sagen
werden spitze den banken auf schalke mit
der musik diederik die ihren exakten
spitze der musik mobil messner und
westdeutschlands booten drauf
juli ich darf weitere vorgesetzte und
gäste auch namentlich begrüßen und
bittet zugleich dass wir das am ende
einen applaus spenden ich entweder einen
respektvollen groß wenn einen
vorgesetzten brigade genannten der
dritten liga brigade reagieren aber sagt
christian kommen er ist nicht nur mein
vorgesetzter er wird auf
hier war gesetzt auch bleiben egal
welchen personen sie waren auf text und
vermuten dienst versehen
ich begrüße und der hohen geistlichkeit
und sie hatten ja heute bereits einen
vor meisterlichen gottesdienst wo sie
auch bereits die schatzkiste die antike
an geplant haben
und ich begrüße auch hier recht herzlich
gerne redet er die katholischen kirche
deutlich vor der evangelischen magister
zuletzt
biete ich jetzt unsere er gäste einen
kräftig applaus für unsere rekruten die
da am ersten märz
vielen dank herr bereits angesprochen
sie haben die kern ausbildung
abgeschlossen erfolge haben es schwer
gewesen was sicherlich schießausbildung
mit dem druck der 77
sie haben viele schießübungen
absolvierten auch gestern unser zweiter
suchen die sind nun die geschlossene tür
selbst überzeugen können content
gezeigten leistungen abgeschlossen
eine klicken
wir begannen sind mit ihren worten sehr
[Musik]
von dem wie das burgenland die schönen
raum graz süd und oststeiermark und alle
wurden jeder und stärker werden uns dann
morgen verlassen und ab montag dann
ihren dienst in der kaserne spaß oder
güssing antreten
alles die wiener und die minister werden
den dienst entweder in der kaserne
letzten antreten
in welcher die eben jetzt gehabt habe
ebenfalls alles gute und 40 soldaten das
anti weinviertler und ein paar wiener
hier wir sehen uns am montag wieder da
wünsche ich alles gute auf die nächsten
fünf monate und satz wetter
ich habe das möchte ich abschließend
jetzt noch an werken drei ziele
ausgegeben
die wende gelang das erste ziel war und
sagen kann
sie haben ihre ausbildung
und um es vom schnee hat geschlossen es
war ihr verdienst attraktion
das zweite ziel dass wir an den strand
geredet
diese angelobung der im internet
übertragen damit ich auch ihren
angehörigen sagen kann wo sie ihre
ausbildung erfolgreich abgeschlossen
sind dass sie bis jetzt super war dass
ihr ärger richtet sich nur 26 märz ein
sonniges frühlingswetter haben
wer für dieses wetter verantwortlich ist
weiß ich nicht
jedenfalls haben sie sich dieses wetter
verdient
ich war 4 dann nochmals gratulieren
wünsche ihnen alles gute für die nächste
zeit beim bundesheer es lebe das
österreichische bundesheer in seinen
stolzen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
us-soldaten und soldaten allerdings
gerade mit der musik in österreich ein
herzliches grüß gott ich denke es ist
eine gute tradition was menschen wenn
sie sich auf den weg
neu besonderen lebensabschnitt mehr in
den vordergrund gerückt werden
so ist es jetzt zu dieser feierstunde
die aufmerksamkeit auf unsere anzüge
lungen der nicht mit der heutigen
anregung bekommen sich offiziell den
auftrag
hier übernimmt somit die aufgabe für
eure heimat einzustehen und der
österreichischen volk zu dienen
viel verantwortung die jungen
staatsbürger zugetraut und zugemutet
wird der begriff zutrauen kommt vom
vertrauen das wort zumuten hat etwas mit
mut
beides braucht ein soldaten um seinen
auftrag zu erfüllen
für diese besondere zeit seit und du
denkst segen gottes
ihr sollt kameradschaft und freundschaft
erfahren und helfende hände mögen euch
stets begleiten
anlässlich dieses festes wünsche ihnen
einen schönen tag gefunden und viel
soldaten für die zukunft
kann man in den quadraten liebe hat sich
gelohnt dass wir sogar den unterrichten
und schießplatz oder im lehrsaal das
probiert zumindest schon auch großen
spaß gemacht und ich was anderes und
heute dieser einteilung schaut sehr echt
schädigers und ich glaube eine
angehörigen wenn auch nur virtuell mit
uns verbunden riesig stolz einen beitrag
zur angelogen hat nämlich gestern heute
schon sowie die rede habe ist ein beet
das uns begleiten mag
du hast uns bewegt unser leben im
füreinander und miteinander zu gestalten
was uns den dienst in unserem er
weißwein des friedens zum wohl unseres
landes verstehen hilfe der bewältigung
der gestellten aufgaben stets den
einzelnen menschen in seiner von dir
geschenke zu erkennen und zu machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch zu hause aber feine kuchen
das bundesheer gibt es über 60 jahre
gerade in den letzten eineinhalb jahren
ist die leistung das wirken des
bundesheeres in der gesellschaft
besonders sichtbar geworden carola dazu
geführt dass das bundesheer noch während
die ausreichend getreten ist ist
übernimmt verschiedenste aufgaben in
unserer gesellschaft
3000 soldaten sind im durchschnitt pro
tag im einsatz und weitere 900 im
ausland das bundesheer ästhetik an der
grenze zur grenzraum überraschung im
inland mehr unterstützung bei der
eindämmung
der verbreitung des virus in gewissen
regionen
es ist tätigen verschiedensten
einrichtungen und es ist auch gefordert
den unterschiedlichsten
ausbildungsaufgaben gerecht zu werden
eine dieser aufgaben ist auch die
ausbildung immer rekruten in weiterer
folge sogar die jüngsten mitglieder
ich hoffe dass er nicht lange sie haben
den ersten wochen gewisse
grundfähigkeiten mitgekommen um in
diesem großen system eingesetzt zu
werden
das sind grundfähigkeiten würde man
sagen zur bedingung von hardware aber
auch software wir gehen mit gegeben und
daher würde ich sagen
wie geht man mit waffen und leisteten
erste hilfe und funkgeräte wie fährt man
ein fahrzeug und michael jacksons
fahrzeugen
normal bin in wien gelebt und vieles
mehr
sie werden das sind unter anderem
kameradschaft disziplin die usa
verlässlichkeit und vieles mehr
gerade diese wertevorstellungen sind
wichtig für eine große organisation wie
das buch anderen organisationen die
ähnliche art und weise sehen vielleicht
nicht so ausgeprägt
ich kann sie nur suchen alle diese dinge
mitzunehmen weiter auszubauen sich diese
werte auch zu hängen
was macht unser zusammenleben leichter
und das macht es leichter für uns als
organisation in auftrag zu erfüllen und
wie ich es gesagt habe die zählten die
zahlen von soldaten die tagtäglich im
einsatz sind sind enorm und wir werden
sehen wie sich das weiter entwickelt und
welche rolle das militär in den nächsten
wochen aber auch zukünftig in einigen
jahren einnehmen wird und ich darf sie
auch das suchen darüber nachzudenken
welche rolle sie in zukunft beim
bundesheer spielen wollen
danke ihnen dafür dass die sechs monate
sind es gibt aber auch möglichkeiten zu
einem berufslaufbahn
in der miliz und vieles mehr mit dem
heutigen tag werden sie in treuer
geologie sprechen und damit eine
verbindung erkennen
eine verbindung zu den kameraden seinen
vorgesetzten zum bundesheer aber auch
zurück gesellschaft zu unseren
mitbürgern und das ist ein unteres band
das sie verbinden wird ihr ganzes leben
lang
ich darf sie ich freue mich auf diese
zusammenarbeit aber ich darf sie auch
versuchen sich diese stellung und dieser
verbindung und dieses treuegelöbnis
bewusst zu sein nehmen sie dass diese
verbindung auch mit freuden an
sie nehmen auch verantwortung auf sich
ich indirekt geraten und gesellschaft
und es liegt an ihnen dieses treffer
hätten diese mit leben zu erfüllen
so fordere ich sie abschließend bedanke
ich mich dafür dass sie den weg zum
bundesheer gewählt haben wie sie wissen
hätten sie auch andere dienste antreten
können
ich bedanke mich auch ein theater
personal voran dem kompaniekommandanten
obmann freizeit seinem team für die
ausbildung unserer jungen soldaten
bedanke mich auch bei der militärmusik
für die umrahmung dieses facebook ist
argumenten denjenigen die versucht haben
unseren jungen rekruten ein
handwerkszeug mit zugehen und ihnen auch
gewissermaßen eine neue familie
wenn auch jetzt in uniform zu bieten
geschätzte kunden ich wünsche ihnen
erfolgreiche sechs monate ich wünsche
unfallfreie sechs monate und ich hoffe
dass ich sie früher oder später wieder
in private bereiche in unterschiedlichen
funktionen begrüßen kann und wieder
sehen kann
und glauben sie mir jeder von ihnen so
wie er dasteht wird notwendig gebraucht
um diese große organisation auch weiter
mit leben zu erfüllen die aufträge
bewältigen zu können und unseren dienst
für die gesellschaft für unsere
bevölkerung auch leisten zu können
es lebe unsere kunden es lebe die dritte
liga brigade es lebe das österreichische
bundesheer geschaffen werden wir kommen
nun zum eigentlichen höhepunkt des
festaktes jetzt das
[Musik]
sprich die lupe und zu schützen
und da war und mit dafür zu verteidigen
und ich glaube alle glücklich und genau
zu befolgen und mit der republik ist und
den österreichischen folgten als nächste
beratung und dünn gegangen bilder
österreichische lange finger flitzen und
brasilien
[Musik]
das ganze
ihre zu wissen der niederösterreichische
landeschef
[Musik]
der brigadier meldet die beendigung der
feierlichen angelobung und um weitere
befehle
danke
[Musik]
a